all right it is well it's not a good day
another day of tragedy we have so many
of them it feels like as you've heard
I'm sure at this point there was an
attack on a mosque two mosques in New
Zealand yesterday 49 people dead as of
the last time I checked the killer
filmed himself live streamed the attack
and that video was unfortunately
everywhere across almost every platform
you can think of within a very short
amount of time
it just was everywhere that's that's the
way things work now the first thing we
should acknowledge here simply is the
human toll of an attack like this the
loss of human life and we should extend
our prayers for those who have been lost
and for their families and I think so
often we forget to do that part because
we jump right into the controversy and
the arguments and everything anyone who
is religious whatever your religion
happens to be if you're religious then
you can imagine and you probably have
imagined because unfortunately we see
this sort of thing so often that you
know whatever your religion is I know
this is something that I think about
every time I go to church it always
crosses my mind about you know is this
gonna be the time when someone walks in
here with a gun where are the exits and
that kind of thing and it's it's not
crazy to think that way so you can omit
you can imagine this special horror of
something like this happening at a house
of worship and we've seen as I said over
the past year we've seen some of the
worst mass shootings in history at
houses of worship just over the last
year we've had New Zealand
pittsburg so those Sutherland Springs
and Texas the church shooting almost 90
people killed between just those three
attacks Charleston too was that was a
few years ago you know we sort of
reflexively call these mass killers
cowards right every time there's any
kind of mass killing we say oh that
person was a coward almost to the point
where the word ceases to have any
meaning because it is so reflexive and
in fact the truth is that this even if
it makes us feel better to assume that
every evil person is a coward that's
actually not the case not just because
someone's an evil person doesn't make
them a coward but to attack a house of
worship I mean that truly is the height
of cowardice so when I call this guy a
coward it is not just reflexive and I'm
not just saying it because he did a
terrible thing he really is the height
of cowardice the only thing more
cowardly is something like Sandy Hook
where you're going and killing
elementary schoolers but it with
something like this you're going after
people who you know or you think will
not be armed now from the reports that
I've read at the second mosque attack
someone did return fire thank God and
and probably saved many lives in doing
so but these you know these areas are
chosen because the thought is that the
people there will be completely
vulnerable and not only unarmed but will
just they're not going to be thinking
about about this they're gonna be
focused on prayer and be in a completely
sort of docile kind of state and that's
why these that's why a house of worship
is chosen it's just it's on top of being
evil and disgusting and all of that it
is just so cowardly as well now speaking
of this scumbag and I thought about
before ie before I turn the camera on I
was thinking about
how exactly to go about this because
it's a difficult thing I believe that it
is important to starve these mass
killers of the attention that they so
desperately crave and especially this
guy clearly wanted attention and so on
one hand you don't want to give it to
him right but I also think that the
truth is important and it's important to
combat false narratives we can't just
allow falsehood to spread and I feel
especially in my if my position is worth
anything if I'm supposed to be doing
anything with this platform its some
supposed to be speaking the truth right
so there have been a lot of false
narratives cropping up around this
particular attack people people have
been blaming certain right-wing
personalities like Candace Owens
they've been blaming certain youtubers
they blamed Donald Trump they blamed you
know so on and so forth
claiming that the killer was inspired by
these people well I did go and read part
of this scumbags mint manifesto and I
hate to even call it a manifesto I mean
that makes it sound more significant
than it really is
it's just ramblings as all it is and he
published seventy some pages of
ramblings before his attack now I didn't
read the whole thing I there's no way I
could possibly do that but I read enough
and I hate that I had to read it at all
but I read enough just to tell you this
that all of the narratives you're seeing
surrounding this attack are false in
fact here's the important point the
scumbag wanted to fuel false narratives
and he basically said as much his his
manifesto is filled with sarcasm and
obvious trolling this is essentially
like an internet troll that is coming to
the real world and and he mentions
well-known names
hot-button issues and so on all because
he wants attention and controversy one
point he said that he you know you used
a gun because he wanted to he want it's
a spark debate in in the United States
about about guns and so on so he's a
murderous a murderous nihilistic coward
and that's all and he's clearly also
legitimately racist
he hates Muslims calls them invaders so
obviously we took throw racist in a
racist murderous nihilistic coward but
the nihilistic part is very important as
well the rest everything else that
you're gonna hear about his political
views his affiliations etcetera etc much
of it is simply false and the important
thing to realize is that reading his
diatribe makes it clear and I don't
recommend reading it by the way it so I
read it so you didn't have to you know
I've told you everything you need to
know about it but reading it makes it
clear unescapable clear that he was a
nihilist with no clear political agenda
and with the desire to stir up division
and discord and to bring attention to
himself I'll just give you one example
he he he says in succeeding sentences he
says first he supports Donald Trump as a
symbol whatever that means and then he
also says he does not support Donald
Trump as a leader or a policymaker so
he's saying he supports Trump and he
doesn't support Trump why is he saying
that so that people can latch on to
whichever angle they want and then argue
with each other so that if you're a
trump supporter you can say oh see
didn't he doesn't like Trump so this is
the the fault of Trump haters and if you
if you hate Trump you could say oh he
likes Trump see it's the fault of people
who like Trump clearly that is the
strategy that this scumbag was going
with very obvious and the media is
willingly playing into it I mean I've
seen this all over the media all over
social media as well people saying oh he
was a trump supporter this and that
and I hate talking about what this
scumbag believed and what he wrote but
it's important that the truth be known
and I don't want I don't think we should
be minute I don't want you to be
manipulated so I'll leave that there I
will put that to the side just wanted to
make the record clear one other thing I
wanted to say is that it's pretty
standard procedure now as you know after
these attacks to hear people mocking
thoughts and prayers right that phrase
and the usual suspects are at it again
with this thing every time their peoples
or thoughts and prayers don't do
anything unsurprisingly Alexandre
occasional Cortez got in on the action
this is what she tweeted she says at
first I thought of saying imagine being
told your house of faith isn't safe
anymore but I couldn't say imagine
because of Charleston Pittsburgh
Sutherland Springs
what good are your thoughts and prayers
when they don't even keep the pews safe
and then she goes on later and she says
thoughts and prayers is reference to the
NRA s phrase used to deflect
conversation away from policy change
during tragedies not directed at the
prime minister of New Zealand who I
greatly admire so to call this
thoughtless and insensitive would be a
massive understatement
first of all thoughts and prayers is in
is the NRA s phrase what does that even
mean does she really think that the NRA
invented thoughts and prayers like this
is the it's a it's a some sort of
conspiracy and they came up with it no
she's not that stupid despite what you
might think this is just opportunism
she's using the bodies of forty nine
dead people to bludgeon her political
opponents as of thoughts and as for
thoughts and prayers the fact is this
even if you don't believe in the power
of prayer the victims clearly did their
families did they died in prayer
literally so now is not the time for the
criticism of prayer and I remember this
every time you have a shooting
a house of worship this same thing
happens I remember it with Sutherland
Springs and the I think was 20 25 or 26
people who were killed shot in cold
blood point-blank range at a church in
in Texas you know about a year ago and
it was the same thing people say oh you
know so you think thoughts and prayers
do that well the thoughts and prayers
couldn't even keep the killer out of the
church
leaving aside how the people who say
that clearly don't understand what
prayer is and what the faithful believe
prayer to be we don't we don't think of
prayer as some sort of magical
incantation where if you say these
certain words enough times you know good
things are automatically going to happen
or there's going to be some sort of
force field put around you to stop bad
things from happening to you that's not
what we think of prayer that if you
don't pray if you're not religious maybe
that's what you think we think but
that's not it prayer is about it's about
union and connection with God first and
foremost that's what it's about and in
fact not every prayer is even a petition
so when we talk about prayer we're not
talking always about asking for things
from God
sometimes prayer is simply adoration
it's worship of God sometimes prayer is
is contemplation simply thinking about
the divine sometimes it's a prayer of
repentance sometimes it's a prayer of
thanks Thanksgiving there are many
different kinds of prayer and it is not
principally about asking for things and
when we the faithful when we see
terrible things happen to people and to
other people of faith even in a church
or a mosque or a synagogue we're not
confused by that we don't think well how
could this have happened when they were
they were praying because we don't
expect prayer to work like that
and we know that terrible things happen
in this world that's why we pray it's
why our faith is so important to us so
you simply you have a misunderstand if
you're going around saying this kind of
thing you have a misunderstanding of
what faith means what religious people
believe of what prayer is you have a
misunderstanding but even aside from
that it just is just not the time can
you have a little bit of sensitivity
these these people believe this they
they died in prayer can't you have a
little bit of sensitivity and leave that
just you know hold off for a little bit
you can you can launch into your anti
prayer ran any other time you've got all
the time in the world to complain about
prayer and talk about and mock it and
say how worthless and stupid it is
you've got all the time to do that you
don't need to do it right now
I mean look even if you think even if
you think the prayer is pointless and
worthless and it does nothing and you're
just talking to yourself and there is no
God whatever even if you think that even
if that's your belief okay
well then then from your perspective
then people pray at times like this to
make themselves feel better and so that
they can commune with each other and it
so fine what does that bother you just
just let them do that then I don't even
understand even if I were to adopt your
perspective I was still not I wouldn't
be out there after a mass shooting say
oh don't don't pray what do you care if
it's just so many people didn't make
themselves feel better than fine what
does that bother you why do you need to
who cares why do you care what happened
to live and let live what about what
happened to letting people live their
lifestyle you don't have to understand
it you don't have to agree you could
think it's stupid doesn't matter
all right and a couple of things I
wanted to talk about today less
important things less serious and tragic
things to talk about so I'm gonna move
on to a couple of those
first of all Beto O'Rourke announced his
candidacy for president yesterday I
don't have a lot to offer on this as I
find news about political campaigns to
be exceedingly boring but I will say one
thing about Beto Rourke
I disagree obviously with his views not
only do disagree in this ruse I think
that his shtick is phony in many ways
but I also think the Conservatives make
a mistake when they take him too lightly
he is he is a formidable political
talent and and he would be a formidable
challenge for Trump now fortunately for
Trump I don't think that he's going to
get the nomination I think the Democrat
Party is at a place right now where a
guy like Beto O'Rourke is probably just
can't win the nomination but if he did
somehow get the nod he would be a tough
out for Trump I think for sure and and
remember Trump has never this is one of
the reasons why it'd be tough for him
Trump has never faced anyone with actual
charisma or political talent so that
that would be a new challenge for Trump
Trump has never faced someone like that
and even outside of the campaign most of
the feuds that Trump has been in have
been with people who are completely
devoid of charisma or talent of any kind
Hillary Clinton Clinton was like a black
hole for charisma she was where crit she
just everything is just sucked in and
obliterated so there's just nothing
there in terms of political talent or
charisma and his number what number one
primary challenger was Ted Cruz who I
like Ted Cruz but Ted Cruz is actually
listed as an antonym for charismatic if
you look up in a thesaurus you'll see
his name there so it would be a new
thing for Trump and Beto is not the only
Democrat with charisma Kamala Harris has
it though I think she's so
and evil she she does have she does have
charisma so there are a few others as
well here's the problem for one thing
O'Rourke is he's good at speaking
off-the-cuff or at least looking seeming
like he's speaking off-the-cuff and then
and also in the process being coherent
and superficially insightful emphasis on
superficially but superficial insight
fools a lot of people there's that there
was a viral video of a Roarke answering
a question during the campaign against
Cruz he was answering a question about I
think it was about the the NFL the
anthem controversy and of course he was
coming out in favor of the players who
were kneeling and he just goes on this
whatever four or five minute thing about
the anthem and the reason went viral and
millions of people shared it is because
everyone was saying oh this is so
insightful and he's just he gets it he
understands I don't agree with the point
of view he was expressing there but the
fact that he can do that
and give you a four or five minute
answer on something seemingly
off-the-cuff and then other people will
go oh wow that was really insightful the
fact that he can do that is is that's a
challenge Trump as I said he's never
faced anyone who could do that Hillary
Clinton definitely could not do that and
the problem is that Trump Trump's
off-the-cuff speaking style is basically
rambling and incoherent
when Trump goes off the coffee just goes
in a million different directions and
it's basically incoherent you can't even
tell what point he's trying to make the
contrast I think between rambling and
coherence and someone with some charm
and charisma speaking coherently is just
not a contrast that will work well for
Trump I'm afraid also beto and there
again are a few Democrats who have this
going for themselves but Beto has
basically mastered the art of coming off
a regular down-to-earth guy and now
again I think I think I think a lot of
that is stick but it doesn't matter this
is politics and if you can come off that
way that's that's a huge advantage and
that's why some of the attacks that
Republicans launched against him during
the campaign in in Texas a lot of those
attacks failed so miserably and I know
you'll say well he lost yeah but it was
Texas this was Texas he had no business
even coming close to winning in Texas
the fact that he came close is stunning
honestly really is and it shows you that
the attacks were not effective at all
attacks like I mean the fact that what
Republicans would try to eat
conservatives are still doing this
they're trying to use the fact that Beto
was in a punk rock band as a younger
person they're trying to use that
against him look this guy was in a band
okay
most people think bands are cool that's
not you you're just making him seem cool
that is not a good line of attack I know
you might if you don't like him you
think that any line of attack is good no
this loser was in a band no when people
see oh he was in a band you know what
people think they think okay he had
friends he was a musician he liked a
party
most people think well that's cool
that's D he was like I was as a younger
person he's just a normal person oh he
had a DUI again nobody cares about the
DUI no one cares whether maybe they
should but they don't listen no one
cares if you had a DUI 20 years ago when
you were a crazy punk rocker bla bla bla
nobody cares about that and a guy who
has matured after being a crazy partying
punk rocker etc that's a story that
people find relatable you know why
because a lot of other a lot of normal
people are like that maybe they weren't
punk rockers but there are a lot of
people who when they were younger they
were kind of crazy they did stupid
things they drank a lot then they
matured and they change so that is a
story that does well for for o'rourke
that's it that when you use that you're
helping
and in fact most people can relate more
to that than they can to the story of a
billionaire real estate developer who
before being a president was a you know
Hollywood celebrity yeah nothing wrong
with that I'm just saying that that's
not that no one can relate to that story
that's not no one is most of us have
never been in that world but we have
been many of us in kind of the world
that Roark was in so that's not a not an
effective line of attack it just makes
him seem normal and it also presents a
difficult contrast for Trump because
Trump I think struggles to come off like
a regular human being sometimes he he's
Trump is there's just so much just
bombast all the time with Trump
constantly and that routine is wearing
thin for a lot of people I know that if
you're a big Trump fan you don't want to
hear this but you need to hear it
because he's good he'll lose in 2020 if
he doesn't change something the the
stick that Trump has now I know when he
goes up and speaks for four hours at a
campaign rally and just rambles about a
million topics if you're a big Trump fan
you think oh this is great what's
awesome this is the it's not it most
most people don't find that compelling
you might because you're a big fan
that's fine but most people don't find
that compelling and I take some there
are a lot of people who did find it
compelling in 2016 and now they don't
anymore because it's just it's old it's
a it's an old thing you got to got to
switch it up you can't stick with that
and it's it doesn't do any good to say
oh yeah well he won like that in 20 yeah
but times have changed that was 2016 he
was running against Hillary Clinton the
most devote the most unlikable human to
have ever existed he had the good
fortune of running against and by the
way a human who didn't even think to go
and campaign in the Rust Belt and he
also had the advantage of no one took
him seriously so no one actually thought
he was going to win so he did a lot of
people that hated him didn't go and vote
against him because they thought he had
no chance he's gonna have none of that
in his favor this time around unless he
runs against unless he has the the great
fortune of running against someone like
Elizabeth Warren well then fine but
that's probably not going to happen if
he pulls someone like Oh
rorke he's not gonna have those
advantages anymore and he's gonna have
to change things up and the for our
unscripted campaign rallies where he's
just doing nothing but throwing red meat
to people who already agree with him
it's it's not going to work and he's
going to lose so if he wants to win in
2020 he's going to need a strategy that
goes beyond just slapping a silly
nickname on his opponent and making fun
of his hand gestures that was Trump's
response yesterday was he was making fun
of O'Rourke's hand gestures and again
conservatives were like oh that's great
this is classic stuff it's that's bush
league maybe that was enough in 2016
it's not gonna be enough this time you
see when you're running against someone
with zero personality and zero charisma
and who and whom nobody likes like with
Hillary Clinton then yeah basically any
strategy will work against her but when
you've got someone who's got some talent
you're not gonna be able to knock them
out by putting a nickname on them that's
not gonna be enough especially when
everyone note sees it coming
it's you don't have the element of
surprise anymore no one is surprised at
all everyone knows what Donald Trump is
about so if he wants to win he's gonna
also had that going for him in 2016 is
that no one had ever seen anything like
this before and they didn't know what to
do with it well now we've all seen it
we're expecting it so Trump if he wants
to win he's gonna need to come with a
move that we haven't seen and I think
that maybe if he could figure out a way
to just come off like a regular person
you know there's a I don't know if
you've ever seen that clip of Trump on
Oprah like 30 years ago there's a clip
that's made the rounds online plenty of
times
Trump is on Oprah and he's talking about
30 years ago he's talking about a lot of
the same things trade and all that he's
took him a lot of the same things that
he talked about now so an impressive
amount of
consistency but if you watch that clip
of Oprah he's saying the same sorts of
things but he comes off like a normal
person he just he's just speaking he's
not rambling he's not it's not bombast
it's not bluster he's not saying things
to get a rise out of people he's not
trolling he's not doing any of that he's
just he seems like a normal person
who knows what he's talking about and it
was actually concerned about the country
and and that's how he comes off in that
clip thirty years ago if he could
somehow rediscover that part of him then
I think he'll present a real challenge
to the other side especially because
they're not gonna expect that and I
think maybe the only waits for him to at
this point may be that part of him is
dead now and there's no reclaiming it
it's quite possible people change but
nowadays you see that part of him mostly
when he's reading scripted speeches but
he didn't write like the State of the
Union address everyone raved about that
so I think and his sycophants will
disagree but I think his best chance in
2020 is to stick to the script to give a
lot of scripted speeches just like that
State of the Union to be a script as
possible to dial things back a little
bit to be as normal as possible I think
that's gonna be his chance to win and I
know that again the sycophants will say
no he just needs to do exactly what he's
been doing all along alright if you want
to encourage him to you know do that if
you if you really think I'll just say
this in closing I think to win there is
going to be a huge huge anti-trump
movement you know at the polls in 2020
obviously there are a lot of people who
absolutely hate him and there's no
denying that right so it seems clear
that Trump if he wants to win he's gonna
need more votes than he got in 2016 it's
gonna need more not less and so you have
to ask has he done anything over the
last two years to earn more supporters
do you think he's earned that you think
what he's doing now is earning more
supporters or is it just keeping them
the same and possibly even losing people
all right uh let's see I guess we'll
move on to two emails I had a couple of
things to talk about but all right well
we'll move on to some emails and we'll
wrap up for a Friday Matt wall show at
gmail.com Matt well show gmail.com this
is from Dennis says hi Matt great show
was always roughly 38 years ago my
little brother attempted to blow out his
candles he managed to lodge his wad of
chewing gum into the center of the cake
I've been scarred since the good news is
that there's an easy solution when the
singing stops and it's time to
extinguish the fire simply clap your
hands directly above the cake the
candles the gush of air created by a
single clap is usually enough to put out
every single candle small children may
have to clap a second time but at least
they're not spreading the plague that
they most certainly would have yes well
if you watch the show a couple days ago
Dennis is referring to I went on a
rather lengthy rant about people blowing
out their birthday candles and spewing
their spittle all over the cake so yeah
clapping now that that seems especially
if you had a little kids birthday party
and you intentionally clap oh yeah over
the candles to put them all out that
will get you some dirty looks but I do
it it's better than someone blowing on
the cake anyway this is from Tom hi Matt
enjoy the show
I listen your recent critique of
academia as a scam and had to agree with
most of what you said as a college
professor I am often embarrassed by my
profession I'm a 55 year old white
straight conservative so I don't fit the
stereotypical academic profile I worked
in industry for 25 years before I
changed careers mostly so I could spend
more time with my kids while I have an
engineering and a an heavy
let's see engineering background I teach
in a college of business that puts us
somewhere between the STEM fields and
the humanities well I can't disagree
with the overall points you made about
academia I wanted to let you know that
there are some of us who are truly
trying to provide our students with
important career skills I teach mostly
MBA students and work hard to impart not
only technical skills but important
practical business skills based on my
prior career although I am conservative
I try and keep my politics out of the
classroom because that's my job keep up
the good work and hold the act the
academy accountable just know that we
are not all left-wing intersexual
ideologues trying to indoctrinate our
youth well Tom I appreciate that and it
is it's always concerning though I
appreciate your email it's always
concerning though when I hear someone
say I'm a college professor and I agree
with you I always I wish that you
wouldn't agree you know I wish that you
would tell me I'm totally wrong but when
even college professors agree that
higher education has in some in many
ways become a scam that's that's that is
concerning but I have a lot of respect
for people like yourself who stay in the
thick of it to try to be at least some
small glimmer of light in the midst of
all this madness I've got a ton of
respect for that you're doing the Lord's
work and keep it up all right let's see
this is from Nathan says hey madam
wondering if you could give some advice
me and my wife are planning to have our
second child congratulations
fortunately we agreed to name our first
daughter in honor of my grandmother but
with the upcoming children we can't seem
to come to an agreement I want my
children to have biblical names like
Peter Noah
Delilah Rebecca etc but she keeps coming
back with names like Matt Maria Maria
Leah what Maria Leah Georgia beau etc it
seems to me like she's coming up with
names for a dog rather than named names
for a child and I've expressed this much
to her she repeats over and over I want
my child to have an interesting name not
an old / common one I'm not sure how how
much common ground can be reached here
any suggestions Nathan I would just
quote Ephesians 5 to your wife wives
must submit to their husbands and if I
actually bring out the Bible
and say coming from in honey let me show
you this let me read you there's an
interesting passage here I think st.
Paul has something to say
actually maybe don't do that that might
be counterproductive just okay this is
what I would first of all Marie Aliyah
sounds like the name of a dr. Seuss
character or maybe some sort of disease
so that's not a good one
Georgia is as common a name as just look
at any map and it has the name Georgia
on it and Bo is a great name for a child
if you want your child to be a cliched
Jacques character from an early 90s high
school sitcom then yeah go with beau
otherwise maybe stick with the biblical
names unless she hates the Bible you
know tell her that what we could name
our kid after unless you hate the Bible
is there something you want to tell God
about that you dislike his book all
right
guilt trip I mean it can work sometimes
so it's worth a shot anyway this is from
James speaking of the Bible says hi Matt
you seem to answer emails about biblical
history a lot so I thought I'd throw
this one out at you one claim I hear all
the time that confuses me is that the
Gospels are anonymous
last I checked though they have names at
the top where does this claim come from
and how do you respond to it
hi James yes I do talk about biblical
history a lot but I should emphasize
that I am NOT a an expert just to be
clear I'm interested in the subject I
read about it a lot but I'm not an
expert so always whenever I give an
answer on a question like this always
check my answer check my work okay go
and look it up for yourself and make
sure that I'm right because don't take
my word for it now yes almost any
mainstream secular scholar that you'll
hear from will say that the Gospels are
anonymous
not just scholars but secular people in
general like to say that's a cell it's
anonymous nobody knows who wrote them
etc where does it come from well it it
doesn't come from thin air we have to
admit it's not like they just invented
this the people who make this claim will
point out correctly that the Gospels
themselves do not claim authorship they
don't the Gospels themselves in the
texts don't claim to have been written
by any particular person so they might
say Gospel of Matthew Mark Luke John at
the top but in the text itself it
doesn't say this is Matthew here's my
account of the life of our Lord and that
is a noticeable fact because the the
epistles do claim authorship at the very
beginning like if you read any of Paul's
epistles they always start with Paul
identifying himself Paul slave of Christ
so on and so forth
this was common for people to do back in
the ancient world and and in today's
world as well if people are you know
offering an account of something they'll
often especially if it's a first-hand
account so that's the other interesting
thing is that the Gospels are written in
third-person so Matthew never says we
went there we did this we we met up with
Jesus and went over there even when
referring to himself he just says he
doesn't say I he just calls himself
Matthew and never hints that he is
talking about himself so the Gospels
themselves never claimed authorship and
they never claimed to be eyewitness
accounts and they are not written like I
witness accounts that that is all true
we can't that's can't be denied I mean
that's absolutely true and so when
someone makes this claim that's what
they're basing it on it is not a
baseless claim and I I'll admit that I
don't really understand why Matthew
didn't write his gospel like an
eyewitness account I kind of wish that
he had honestly would be I wish he had
but he hadn't but as you point out that
that's all true but as you point out
that there are there are names right at
the top so it's hard to overlook that
part of it does say the Gospel of
Matthew gospel of seems pretty clear-cut
and what's really important is that we
don't have any complete manuscripts that
lack that identification
as far as I know as far as I know and
someone will correct me if I'm wrong but
we don't have now we have gospel
fragments that are just little pieces of
the Gospels that obviously don't say
gospel love because it does it's only
just a little part of the page but of
all the completed of all the whatever
hundreds of completed manuscripts we
have there is not a single one that does
not have that identifier at the top and
there also is not a you know for
instance of we don't have something like
the text of the Gospel of Matthew but at
the top it says Gospel of Luke or
whatever where things are mixed matte
and mismatched so that's a significant
fact as well the Gospels as far as we
can tell have always had these
identifiers now we don't have the
originals though we don't have we don't
have the originals we don't have copies
of the originals we don't have copies of
copies of copies of copies at least not
in complete form so strictly
historically speaking we don't know
historically speaking we don't know what
kind of identification they had
originally we can't say as a matter of
history for an absolute fact
which means secular people the most they
can claim is that the Gospels might be
anonymous or the most they can do is say
the Gospel allegedly written by Matthew
or something like that but when they
when they come out and just say oh
Matthew didn't write that gospel it's
anonymous they're going they and then
they know this if they know if they've
read this if they've researched the
topic at all they know that they are
going far beyond where the evidence
actually leads them because as far as we
know it has always said the Gospel of
Matthew we don't have any evidence that
there was ever a point when the Gospel
of Matthew did not say Gospel of Matthew
and obviously if we had the original
document which we don't I wish we did we
don't if we had it and the original
document said Gospel of Matthew well
then that would put the whole claim to
rest
wouldn't it if it said that on the
original document then clearly there you
go
we can't say as a matter of history that
it absolutely did say that but we can
say as a matter of history as far as we
know in all likelihood this you know
Matthew wrote the Gospel of Matthew and
so the secular people yeah I think in
theirs in their zeal to discredit the
Bible they they often step far beyond
where the evidence actually takes them
so they're they're not content to just
point to this or that difficulty in the
the scriptures and there are
difficulties and there are things that
are difficult to understand like why for
instance the eyewitness accounts are not
written like eyewitness accounts so they
could point that out and just leave it
there but no they want to go for the
certainty they want to prove that oh no
this is all just bogus and then they go
off on so in a way ironically they're
they're doing what they accuse us of
doing which is having a sort of
unfounded certainty which they
themselves often demonstrate all right
we'll leave it there thanks for watching
everybody thanks for listening and have
a great weekend Godspeed